[Music]
we're hoping for a wedding after the
bats arrest disease and now we know
there is an engagement for back after re
broke things off with her and probably
the worst way possible but now it isn't
Becca's turn to break some things eg
old-line Florence emo is with the bass
aret blow out the steam I feel so good
on my body I feel like it's Grange but
in the best possible way I mean you
smashed the couch that Arie broke up
with you hon tell me about that I have
been saving this great couch I hate that
Coach and you sobbing teasers all the
time
so the fact that this have fed up I'm
like Becca's smashing first one-on-one
date is with 28 year old Colorado sales
rep Blake so let's talk about Blake cuz
I just met him at he's real cute how did
Blake get the one-on-one on the very
first night he was somebody who just
made me laugh the entire time I was with
him and so I know how many intense and
intimidating the first one that what do
you think Ari will react to seeing us
because he said he's gonna watch your
season
I mean honestly he made his bed now lie
in it and in it's full of broken glass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]